how does it feel right now for you Joe
to be on top of the world not one not
two but three like blockbuster major
major movies coming out this year I'm
sure just really fortunate to be working
full stop and to be doing it with people
with that I really admire and filmmakers
that I think of brilliant and casts and
the whole team that uh that are
brilliant and very very talented from
very luck now that was Joe Allen talking
to ETS Kelty night about his very busy
year in Hollywood he's talking to her
therefore at Mary Queen of Scots which
he stars in and here's the thing guys
you know Joe as Taylor Swift's boyfriend
but Joe's about to have a moment o 2018
has been the year of Joe and we're
thinking 2019 will be the year of a
Lister Joe let's talk about the glow up
for Joe the Joe glow first up as you
heard Kelty Nights stay there okay Joe
has a total of four films out this year
ok many of them coming out in the second
half of this year but first operation
finale he starred as a former SS officer
a lot of historical films by the way for
Joe a lot of period pieces now he also
appears in the highly critically
acclaimed boy erased starring Nicole
Kidman Russell Crowe Lucas hedges that
came out in November and things are just
picking right up all through the fall
for Joe we're falling into Joe the
favorite comes out this month and Joe
plays Emma Stone's love interest it
actually comes out Friday and let's take
note here what's interesting is he plays
Emma Stone's love interest Emma Stone is
a good friend of Joe's girlfriend Taylor
Swift so you know keeping it small deep
enough a little small circle in
Hollywood and then you just saw him in
that interview for Mary Queen of Scots
that hits theaters in December he takes
on the role of Queen Elizabeth's
counselor we love Joe in a costume
there he is with Emma Stone in the
favorite people are talking about this
movie again it critically acclaimed
movies for Jill all around which is part
of why we're thinking it's about to be a
big moment for Jo boy erased the
favorite and Mary Queen of Scots all
getting awards season buzz and you know
what award season loves a period piece
okay they love a transformation love to
award and give those accolades out plus
not only is Jo really and by the way
guys want to put into perspective before
this Jo is in these numbers aren't exact
but roughly one movie a year for like
2016 and 2017 and now all of a sudden
four major movies in 2018 again
alongside stars like Nicole Kidman
Russell Crowe Margot Robbie Emma Stone
it's big and not only is he exploding in
the acting world but the modeling world
- Oh Jo landing a casual campaign he was
the face of Pradas men's spring and
summer 2018 ascension campaign okay
okay Jo mm-hmm let's not forget there it
is there it is
remember Taylor Sutton Taylor's lyrics
you're so gorgeous songs and lyrics
about the blue eyes mm-hmm this is Jo
again for Prada and in pratas
fall/winter menswear campaign called
observe eeeh I did not even know
campaign set names but now I do
jo can pose for for any of us every day
I think and again Taylor Swift okay so
the pair have definitely kept their
relationship low-profile but they've
been getting a little more out there in
social media Jo did join Instagram he
did acknowledge Taylor in an interview
although all he said was that he didn't
want to speak too much on his private
life in a recent magazine interview and
they've been there for each other at the
big career moments jo has attended
Taylor's concerts we have spotted her at
movie premieres of his most recently the
two were at the favorite premiere in LA
this month now that doesn't necessarily
meant you know Taylor posing on the red
carpet but she's been there and even
though the two are very private about
their relationship they have shown
things off like I said
just a little on social media just to
touch and when I say just a touch I mean
really really subtly they both posted a
picture posing with the same cactus on
the same day hey we'll take what we can
get
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]